ROMAN NURIK: Hello, and welcome
once again to Android
Design & Action.
I'm your host, Roman Nurik.
ADAM KOCH: Hey, guys.
My name's Adam Koch.
And today, we have a special
guest joining from London.
NICK BUTCHER: Hey,
I'm Nick Butcher.
It's good to be here in person
shooting a show, rather than
just a little head across
the Atlantic.
ROMAN NURIK: So today's
episode is about the
onboarding experience,
basically, everything from the
point in which the user, you
know, downloads, maybe finds
your app in the Play Store,
installs it, and then
starts using it.
So basically, just those kind of
initial crucial few moments
between the point in
which they install,
and they start running.
We're going to talk about ways
to make that optimal, at least
as optimal as possible.
NICK BUTCHER: The old saying,
you only get one chance to
make a first impression.
This is what this show
is all about.
ROMAN NURIK: Exactly, exactly.
So with that, let's jump
into the slides.
NICK BUTCHER: And I'm
particularly proud about this
title card we have
for onboarding.
Onboarding, get it?
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, like a
snowboard, boarding, you're on
a board, yeah.
[LAUGHS]
NICK BUTCHER: Thanks
very much.
It's my contribution.
ROMAN NURIK: [LAUGHS]
So let's get in here.
So the first thing we wanted
to talk about is that last
week or, I guess, two weeks ago,
we did an episode on our
top 10 anti-patterns or
common UX issues that
we saw during review.
And number two, basically one
removed from the last one, was
a poor onboarding
user experience.
And that included a couple
things, requiring registration
up front, using splash
screens.
We're going to talk about
all the details here.
But we wanted to spend an entire
Android Design & Action
episode just talking
about this,
because it's so, so crucial.
So the first thing is about
splash screens.
Adam, you want to talk
about splash screens?
ADAM KOCH: Yeah.
So as you mentioned the other
week, don't show them.
[LAUGHTER]
ADAM KOCH: Let's remember our
sort of content first
principles here.
A splash screen is really not
content, it's just another
roadblock, another hurdle in the
way to the user getting to
your application and the
actual content in your
application.
Now, of course, some people say,
well, I really want to
make sure my brand is
recognized, that the user
knows my brand.
Well, in Android, we still
think brand is very
important, of course.
But you can use the action bar
icon and, of course, theming
and selecting that accent color
to really show off your
brand instead.
And as you see here and in the
screenshots, Google Play is a
pretty good example of using
that icon and this sort of
accent color to really show off
the different silos within
the different Google
Play Store.
ROMAN NURIK: And I know a bunch
of people might think,
well, a lot of people think,
that splash screens are
important for when you have,
you know, content that you
need to load before
you show your UI.
And I'd say my rebuttal to that
is you don't necessarily
need to block the entire
UI, right?
There's probably something that
you can show of value.
At least show the top-level
navigation of your app.
You know, you can always show a
loading spinner or a really
friendly loading spinner,
something that involves your
brand even.
It doesn't have to be the
built-in loading spinner.
You can show that in place where
content will show up.
You don't necessarily need to
block everything and have the
user sit there patiently
waiting, just looking at your
pretty logo before actually
showing your UI.
It's actually a good chance to
let them start exploring and
learning about the different
sections in the app rather
than, you know, just showing
them nothing.
ADAM KOCH: Yeah, even if the
content isn't there, maybe
they can open the drawer, see
what's available there.
Maybe they can go to Settings
and see what
settings are available.
They can do other things,
potentially, in the
application.
ROMAN NURIK: Yep.
OK.
NICK BUTCHER: And I think the
worst offenders on the splash
screens are the splash screens
which decide to go full, full
screen and completely hide
away the status bar.
That's a double--
don't do it.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
ADAM KOCH: Or the ones that
are playing sound or
music in the front.
Argh.
[LAUGHTER]
ROMAN NURIK: Yes, exactly.
Actually, one of my favorites is
you have this splash screen
up, and then you press back or
press home or something,
because you just don't want
to use the app anymore.
And then, you know,
the splash screen
lasts for three seconds.
But then you press back and,
three seconds later, the
actual next screen just shows up
randomly because the splash
screen hasn't recognized that
you've backed out of it.
So it's just that there are so
many things that can go wrong
with splash screens, and they're
just a very poor user
experience.
Just don't use them at all.
All right.
NICK BUTCHER: I think
we've covered that.
[LAUGHTER]
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, I think we've
beaten that dead horse,
or whatever.
I'm really bad at idioms.
[LAUGHTER]
ROMAN NURIK: All
right, anyway.
Let's move on.
So the next thing we wanted
to cover is tutorials.
So we're going to spend some
time talking about a couple of
main parts to onboarding.
The first will be tutorials,
then we'll
talk about login flow.
Finally, I think we'll talk
about onscreen overlays.
So for tutorials, one thing,
before we jump into all the
details, we do want to mention
is that there is pretty good
coverage of a lot of
these things in the
Android Design Guide.
So if you visit this link here,
you'll see the specifics
on when and when not to
show unsolicited help.
So tutorials are one of those
examples of unsolicited help,
basically help that you're kind
of pushing to the user
without them actively
requesting it.
So we very clearly kind
of advice against it.
You know, they're interruptions,
they're usually
not necessary, and so on.
And so generally, this is
something that's covered in
our guidelines.
But besides that, we wanted to
kind of add additional color,
I guess, to some of these
guidelines and kind of explain
some of the reasoning
for them.
So one of the first things you
should think about is there's
a couple types of tutorials,
right?
There's speedbump tutorials,
mandatory tutorials that you
need to kind of go through
before you get into the app.
And we'll talk about
that in a second.
That's the type of thing
that you shouldn't do.
And the reason that you
shouldn't do them is,
generally, that it's a sign that
you actually may need to
simplify your app.
Maybe there's too
much going on.
Maybe your app is just
not simple enough.
So certainly, its generally a
bad sign if you think you need
a pretty complex onboarding
flow.
Some ways around using the speed
bump tutorial style is
using something like
what Google Play
Movies is doing here.
And it's still, you know,
communicating value.
It's still, I guess, expressing
the value
proposition of the app, but it's
doing so in a very direct
and contextual way.
So info cards is one
of the things that
Google Play Movies features--
it's one of the features
that they have.
Basically, you know, when you're
watching a movie, you
press pause, you actually see
information about the
character onscreen.
But the idea here is that we
could have thrown up a
tutorial that forces you
to go through it,
but we didn't here.
So the idea here was that once
you get to the point at which
this starts to become
interesting, like the user may
start caring about this at this
point, we actually show
this card or this
tutorial card.
And they can obviously very
easily dismiss it, or they can
just ignore it.
You know, if they just start
scrolling down, they'll see
their content.
So it's very passive.
It's not super obtrusive.
But it does communicate the
value, and it does it in a
contextual way.
If I was in a different section
of the app, perhaps it
would show me a different
kind of hint that
there's a feature there.
NICK BUTCHER: I think the key
to this kind of goods
tutorial, if you will,
is it's non-blocking.
I think anything which is
blocking, especially mobile
dialogues-- one of my personal
pet peeves--
anything that's you saying to
user, hey, I know better than
you what you need to be doing
now, is kind of aggressive.
And it kind of breaks any flow
or any task they're trying to
accomplish.
So I think, while this is still
unsolicited help, I
guess, it doesn't have that
blocking feature, which makes
it so much better.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
So just to specifically talk
about speedbump style
tutorials, these are the kind
of tutorials where-- you see
here an example--
you basically flip through a
couple of pages, and maybe at
the end there's a sign-up
for something.
But basically, this
is not the app.
This is a separate flow before
you get to the actual app that
is mandatory.
So this is definitely
something that
you should try to--
NICK BUTCHER: I wonder how many
of these screens people
actually even read, how
many just see this--
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, swipe,
swipe, swipe.
[LAUGHS]
NICK BUTCHER: --and immediately
try and home in
on, how do I get past this,
and just mash that button.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
And actually, I will say that
we should probably admit at
this point that one of our
reference apps, the Google I/O
app, has a speedbump.
Not a tutorial, but it's a
different onboarding flow.
And it's definitely something
we should try to address for
the next release.
But here, you know, some of
the things that you should
think about.
If you absolutely have to do
something like this, if
management sends down the word
that you must have this kind
of tutorial flow, definitely
allow immediately skipping.
So don't force the user to go
next, next, next, next, next,
and then get started.
So give them the option
to skip right away.
Also, and Nick will talk about
this in depth later, but if
you're going through a couple
screens that tell you about
the app, and then at the very
end, you have to kind of make
decisions, like sign up or
register or whatever, that's
just another way to
stop the funnel of
engagement with your app.
So definitely try to
avoid these kinds
of speedbump tutorials.
All right, I think we've
talked about speedbump
tutorials quite a bit.
But there's a couple of other
tutorial type things you can
do to educate users about your
app, to communicate the value
proposition.
The first, and this is very
obvious, very simple, is doing
so via your Google
Play listing.
A lot of the features that are
available in the developer
console are there so that
you can kind of have a
conversation with your users
at the perfect time, right
before they install,
right before they
start using your app.
So things like the
product video.
That's very important.
Google Keep is actually
a really good example.
When you press Play here, this
actually has a pretty high
level of prominence on the
page, so it draws your
attention to this.
This video, you start
pressing play.
And the video that Google
Keep has provided has
a very strong narrative.
It actually walks you through,
kind of, one flow, one user
using the app.
It actually talks about the
features, but you actually see
the person interacting
with the UI.
So actually, it's a nice way to
kind of imagine yourself in
their shoes.
You can kind of fill
in the gaps.
This is how I would probably
use the app.
And then, obviously,
screenshots.
The screenshots are a really
good way to communicate what
your app does, especially if
your UI design is very good
and very clear.
You can immediately kind of
understand what the app does
and how it works just by looking
at the screenshot.
NICK BUTCHER: One thing I would
say on the screenshots
as well is be careful of the
order you put them in.
Quite often, I'll see
screenshots uploaded for
application, and it seems like
they're in the order in which
you might go through
the application.
So in some apps I've even seen
a splash screen uploaded as
the first screenshot.
And then a login screen.
And then, maybe further down the
line, perhaps once you're
into the actual content within
the application.
And that's a real shame, because
as you can see here on
the screenshot from the
web, there's only
room for one or two.
And this is even more
exaggerated
when you're on a device.
So you'll probably see the
video and maybe one
screenshot, perhaps half of the
second one coming in here.
So you really want to be sharing
your hero moments, the
thing that really, clearly
expresses what this
application is all about first,
and then forget about
these other ancillary screens.
ROMAN NURIK: For sure.
ADAM KOCH: And of course
showing screenshots for
different form factors.
ROMAN NURIK: Yes.
ADAM KOCH: And don't forget
to do that as well.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, because, you
know, if I'm on a device,
if I'm on a 10 inch tablet, I
want to see what it's going to
look like on my device.
ADAM KOCH: Mhm.
NICK BUTCHER: Mhm.
ROMAN NURIK: If I'm on a four
inch phone, I want to see
exactly what it's going to
look like on a phone.
All right, moving on.
Another way to communicate,
again, your value proposition
or educate your users, give
them a tutorial about your
content, is through
the empty state.
And this is actually one of my
favorites, not because this is
specifically my app, but this
is one of my favorite
opportunity moments, in
the empty states.
So you know, most apps
these days have
collections of things.
You know, they have screens
where there's collections of
things, collections of movies,
collections of, in this case,
extensions for a, clock.
There's lots of different
lists.
Too often we see developers
missing the opportunity of
that empty state.
When there's nothing in that
list, use that as the
opportunity to talk
to your user.
Tell them how to add things to
that list, why they should add
things to that list, actually
put buttons in there in that
empty state that will let
them take action.
Fix the problem of
the empty state.
Generally, people don't
want an empty state.
They want it to be
populated, right?
So one of the ways in which
you can do that is you can
just simply use that empty state
for all sorts of things.
In this example, this is the
DashClock app that I wrote.
Before you add any extensions,
you get greeted with this
screen here.
And then, you can press this
button to add an extension.
As soon as you add something,
you kind of start seeing the
full populated list.
And it's very easy to do from
a development standpoint.
You basically just provide an
empty view for the list.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
Quite commonly, you might
imagine-- well, quite often I
see screens which might be like
this on the left, but
it's just empty screen with
maybe a small plus in the
action bar.
And it's such a missed
opportunity.
ROMAN NURIK: Right, yeah.
One thing I will say here is
that there's just a bit too
much text here.
Probably just be very visual,
not really immersive, but just
be very visual on this
screen if possible.
Here, I kind of didn't
do that.
Anyway.
So let's move on to
the next screen.
Another important way to
communicate your value
proposition, to explain to users
how to use your app, is
to pre-populate it with, how you
like to say, bootstrapped
content, right?
So this is an example
from Michael Pardo.
It's an app called Quotes
and gives you your
stock quotes, obviously.
And so one way he could have
designed this app is that when
you first install it, and you
open it up, it just has no
quotes in there, right?
It's a blank list.
And it doesn't show you
any interesting data.
Maybe it just shows you the
S&P index or whatever.
But what he decided to do here
is he decided to actually
pre-populate your portfolio
with a couple of
common stocks here.
They have a CAKE.
I'm not sure if that's like
Cheesecake Factory.
PIZZA, which is probably one
of the delivery services.
And so you kind of immediately
see the value of the app.
You immediately see the data
you're working with.
You know, obviously, you can
very quickly remove them.
You just long press, select
them all, and just remove.
Or you can just add to it.
But it's actually just a very
nice, simple way to just
immediately get started.
So I think that was
it for tutorials.
Any parting words on tutorials
before we move on, guys?
NICK BUTCHER: No, I think
that's covered it.
ADAM KOCH: Yeah.
ROMAN NURIK: All righty.
[LAUGHTER]
ROMAN NURIK: Let's do it.
Nick, take it away for
login registration.
NICK BUTCHER: Yes.
This is one of my pet peeves,
the login experience and
registration.
So the first thing, let's say,
for a login is that you should
really be delaying it
until it's kind
of absolutely necessary.
Just like those speedbump
tutorials that we looked at
earlier, it's another thing to
do when you already kind of
quite cognitively loaded.
The first time you run an
application, there's a lot
going on, right?
You're kind of getting used to
it, you know, the way it looks
and feels, the way the
navigation is laid out.
You're understanding what
the app is doing.
And if you're throwing on all
these extra layers of stuff,
then it's just a lot for the
ease of the process.
So by far and away, I'd
say delay it until
the last moment possible.
And the second point I wanted
to make here is people are
probably more likely to actually
complete the login if
they can clearly understand
why it's necessary.
So an example of this, a great
example of this I was showing
here, is the Tumblr
application.
So when you install Tumblr, you
get the opportunity to log
on, but you don't have to.
You can immediately start
using the application.
You can explore different Tumblr
blogs, and you can
actually take kind of logged-in
type actions.
So for example, here I haven't
actually logged into the
application, but I've already
been able to go through and
start following people.
And if I were to then decide
to log in and sign up, it
would then take all those
actions which I've already
done and just merge them into
the account I've just created.
So it's a truly wonderful
example.
And in this example
here as well.
So if once I've followed a
blog, if I try to do any
actions that obviously requires
login, so if I tried
to like it or comment on
something, at that point, it
then says, hey, you need to
be logged in to do this.
And I can clearly
understand why.
It's demonstrated it's value
to me already, and I'm much
more likely, I think,
to complete it.
ROMAN NURIK: It's kind
of like an inherent--
it's a very contextual almost
direct manipulation in the
sense that it's very clear that
when I'm pressing this
and I see a sign in dialogue,
the reason to sign is because
this won't work without that.
NICK BUTCHER: Right.
ROMAN NURIK: Whereas, if you
were to ask somebody to sign
in in the very beginning as part
of that tutorial flow,
there's no expression
of value, right?
It's not clear.
It's very indirect, if it's
even there at all.
NICK BUTCHER: Right.
Absolutely.
OK.
And the next step is when you
do go on to provide logon.
Logging on can be kind of
a painful experience.
It often involves data
entry, which
isn't always the easiest.
And it's often a pain for you
as well, having to kind of
manage and secure passwords
and so on and so forth.
So an alternative might be to
consider using some of the
common logon providers.
People are likely to have a
bunch of accounts on their
device already.
So you might have a Google
account, a Facebook account,
Twitter account, some of
these common providers.
And they offer much faster and
easier logon services.
Yeah, we're particularly a fan
of the Google+ logon, because
most Android users, well, every
Android user has a Gmail
account to sign in to
the Play Store.
So there's a good chance
they'll be able
to log in with that.
ROMAN NURIK: And another thing
is, you know, even with
Facebook, right-- a lot of users
have Facebook installed.
When you use their SDK rather
than using a separate,
web-based flow, when you use the
SDK, you actually benefit
from the user's account
already on the device.
You don't even have to actually
type in your Facebook
user name and password or
Facebook email and password.
You basically touch it.
It knows that you already
logged in.
It asks you to confirm
and so on.
And obviously, with Google+,
it's the same way.
It's actually--
NICK BUTCHER: Pretty seamless.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, it's
very, very, seamless.
Very much worth it.
NICK BUTCHER: Definitely.
Oh yeah, one point we wanted to
make on that is to include
an email alternative.
Some people just aren't
that comfortable.
You know, they perhaps might be
worried, is this going to
publish stuff my timeline,
and so forth.
And some people are just
adverse to it.
So you know, while we definitely
recommend this as a
great way to go, we would
definitely say include an
alternative.
ROMAN NURIK: Yep.
NICK BUTCHER: All right.
And as an aside while we're
talking about login, one of my
favorite things is when you
actually remove the need to
log in altogether.
And that's offered quite neatly,
I think, by Google+,
And so if you choose to go
down that route and you
already have a popular web
property, if the user signs in
on the web properties in the
same Google+ account, it'll
actually pop and offer them,
hey, would you like to install
the Android app at
the same time?
So it's a great, great
discovery mechanism.
But simply, the greatest thing
is that the user will be
automatically logged in already
in the Android app.
So you skip the need for
this altogether.
Fantastic.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, it's one
of the best ways to remove
friction, right?
NICK BUTCHER: Mhm.
ROMAN NURIK: That's probably
what, you know, the business
folks are always
thinking about.
It's always about the
funnel, right?
How do we maximize the funnel?
NICK BUTCHER: Exactly.
ROMAN NURIK: How do
we minimize the
roadblocks in the funnel?
And this is one of the
best ways to do that.
NICK BUTCHER: Cool.
So that's particularly fun.
So on from login, we're
talking about the
registration steps.
So I want to say here do offer
to sign up on device.
I find it quite frustrating
when an application hasn't
implemented a registration step,
so it kind of boots me
out to a web view or something
like that, which might have
worse data entry and form
filling capabilities.
So I definitely urge you to
include it within your
application.
But try to make it as painless
as possible.
So as we were saying, data entry
on mobile devices isn't
always the most fun experience,
especially at this
critical time when you're trying
to get someone to sign
up for your service.
Yeah, think of that funnel.
So you want to keep it as
painless as possible.
So here's a kind of concocted
example, which is kind of
trying to prove the
point like--
[LAUGHTER]
ADAM KOCH: Social
security number?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, make it
as simple as possible.
Don't ask someone to enter an
email address on the phone and
then confirm it.
I mean, that's pretty
painful, right?
And some other step.
So I'm going to walk you through
some improvements to
this screen here.
So the first thing I'd say is
to remove repetitive or
nonessential fields here.
So already, this screen is
starting to look a little bit
better if we got rid of having
to repeat both your email and
password and some extra
information, which might not
be completely essential
to sign up.
And you can maybe prompt for
it later on when they
understand the value proposition
of that or on a
different kind of meeting.
So already, this is starting to
look a little bit better.
The next step, one of my
personal favorites, here is to
suggest an email if the user
starts filling it in.
So your Android device knows
a lot about you.
He already knows the email
addresses, maybe some user
names that you've entered.
So once the user starts typing--
or you could offer
this as a pick from list if
you want, then do suggest.
One thing to be wary of--
I've seen some implementations
of this where they just see if
there's already an email address
on the device, and
then they just prefill it.
But they don't let you pick,
which isn't great for users
who have more than one account
on the device.
So definitely let them switch
between multiple accounts if
they have that.
But yeah, already, this has
gotten so much easier.
Just with a couple of key taps,
I can just pick from
this list here.
ROMAN NURIK: And one of the
questions that, actually, we
discussed earlier was, how do
you actually show this list?
Right?
NICK BUTCHER: Mhm.
ROMAN NURIK: Do you show an
additional affordance to pick?
NICK BUTCHER: Mhm.
ROMAN NURIK: And certainly,
if you use the Google Play
Services SDK, there's actually
something called an account
picker that's a dialogue
that pops up.
And that actually doesn't
require any permissions.
And so if you wanted to show the
account picker dialogue,
you could have an additional
button next to this field,
rather than a drop down.
But if you do decide to go for
a drop down, which is also
very nice, the way I'd probably
do this is, as soon
as the text field is focused,
drop down the list.
And then, as it loses focus,
collapse that list.
As an alternative, you could
have a conditional kind of
spinner type affordance on the
side that pops up the list.
But generally, it's probably
best to just show the list
immediately.
And I think that's maybe how the
autocomplete stuff works
by default, but I'm
not quite sure.
NICK BUTCHER: Great, cool.
Another side note we've added
here is to prefer email to
user names.
I don't know about you, but I
just find when I'm forced to
pick a username rather than just
use my email address it's
just another thing I'm not
going to remember.
ROMAN NURIK: Right.
NICK BUTCHER: Whereas, it all
comes back to email at the end
of the day anyway, so you can
reset it and so forth.
ROMAN NURIK: Mhm.
The worst is when there's a
service where the username is
your email, and it
says username.
Just say email.
Just ask for the
person's email.
NICK BUTCHER: Absolutely.
And yeah, it works really,
really well on Android,
because you're able to create
a device for [INAUDIBLE]
as well.
So there we go.
So next up, passwords.
So we've said here,
make it optional.
So you can just not require
users to enter a password.
You could do something like
auto-generating one, prefill
it in, and let them cycle it
or something like that.
You could just say
it's optional.
Some users will want to set
it, some users might not.
But my preferred option would
be just to probably omit it
altogether.
I mean, I'm probably going to
enter something very weak or
very quick anyway.
I'd rather just, it's
in the background.
It's generated, saying super
secure or something like that.
And I can always just hit the
Forgot Password or Reset
button, should I really, you
know, want to get access to
that password or if I've
forgotten it somehow.
ADAM KOCH: And maybe later, when
you're on your desktop,
when you have a real keyboard,
you can get that email and
actually fill out a
real password or
something like that.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, you get the
email like, click here to
actually set a password,
or something like that.
NICK BUTCHER: So thinking back
to that kind of final analogy
of how many people are going
to get through this step.
If think back to that first
screen with all those fields
and so on, rather than just one,
which is going to help me
fill in the only field anyway by
suggesting something and a
button to hit sign up, you've
got to imagine that the funnel
is a lot better than this.
ROMAN NURIK: One thing I want
to add is with passwords.
One of my biggest pet peeves
is when there are passwords
that require symbols
and capital letters
and all this stuff.
And generally, it's
a bad practice.
But a lot of people use
the same type of
password or the same--
it might even be a
strong password.
It may be very long.
But you know, people like to
use similar passwords, and
when you ask them to start
introducing symbols and all
these arbitrary constraints, it
actually makes them forget
their password.
I mean, I don't know
how many times--
I mean, it's a bank password.
But some of my bank passwords,
I mean, I've probably had to
reset them a bunch of times,
or my account for cable or
something like that.
Generally, try to enforce it
maybe on minimum size but not
so much on symbols.
And there's actually a really
funny XKCD about arbitrary
password restrictions.
Basically, I think the result
was if you have a very long
string of just regular words
like, hello there, my name is
John, or something and if
they're completely random
words with no symbols, no
anything, the entropy of that
is actually a lot higher than
a very short password, let's
say eight characters long,
with a whole bunch
of symbols and stuff.
You know, think about that
before you require people to
use to provide symbols.
NICK BUTCHER: I think,
generally, just don't get into
the game of holding passwords
if you can.
I think these social providers,
you know, Facebook,
Google, Twitter, spend a lot of
time and money and thought
and engineering into keeping
things like this secure.
And if you have the option of
not doing that, that's pretty
attractive, I think.
You don't want to be the one who
loses someone's database
of passwords or something.
ROMAN NURIK: Right, exactly.
NICK BUTCHER: Oh, and one other
note, a tiny one here,
is that you can also help the
user out by replacing where
the enter key would normally be
on the keyboard with some
kind of text which
is contextual
to what you're doing.
So you know, you quite program
to type and then hit Next or
whatever that button is.
And if that actually does
something, and when the user
hits that and it's the same as
hitting the onscreen sign up
button, it's just another tiny
thing that will help the user
to complete this flow easier.
ROMAN NURIK: Yep.
ADAM KOCH: Yeah, I guess similar
to that as well, in
case there are other fields that
you need to click, like
maybe a phone number, you can
set the data type on that
field appropriately so the
keyboard adjusts itself to
sort of optimize
for that field.
ROMAN NURIK: Mhm.
You'll actually notice
that here this is
an email type field.
So you automatically get the
at sign and the dot sign.
NICK BUTCHER: And there's
other fields.
We talked about email quite
a lot, that you
can query the device.
All right, I mean there are
other fields you can query for
for, I think, Ice Cream
Sandwich and beyond.
The device has a concept
of the user's profile.
So with their permission, you
can ask for their first name,
last name--
ROMAN NURIK: And their
avatar photo.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah,
avatar to photo.
You can also get telephone
number--
ADAM KOCH: Mhm.
NICK BUTCHER: --if you're
on a phone type device.
So each of these will cost you
a permission, but it depends
if it's critical to your--
ADAM KOCH: How important
it is, yeah.
NICK BUTCHER: Then that might
ease and increase sign ups.
ROMAN NURIK: All right,
shall we move
on to onscreen overlays?
ADAM KOCH: Yeah, sure,
let's do it.
So this is pretty quick,
but onscreen overlays.
So the general rule of thumb
here is avoid them.
[LAUGHTER]
NICK BUTCHER: I think I've seen
enough with those kind of
hand-drawn styled arrows
coming out.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
ADAM KOCH: Yeah.
Yeah, exactly.
In particular, you know, you
should avoid them for common
UI patterns.
So we're talking action bar.
You really don't need to tell
the user how to use these
things again.
Yeah, the other thing we
mentioned here was the
navigation drawer.
And I don't think we mentioned
this yet, but there's actually
a recommended pattern for
the navigation drawer.
When the user first loads the
app, you can actually open
that navigation drawer
for them, just for
discoverability, almost like
a tutorial in itself.
NICK BUTCHER: Animate to open a
drawer, because that teaches
the gesture.
ADAM KOCH: Exactly.
And then, the first time they
actually go and use the
drawer, they close it or
open it themselves.
You can set a flag there, and
then you don't need to open it
again on future times they
open the application.
So you really don't need an
onscreen overlay to sort of
help the user discover
that Droid can use
another method like that.
ROMAN NURIK: And generally,
users are learning things like
the drawer, like the action bar
overflow, by using apps
like Gmail, like Google Keep,
like Google Drive.
You know, a lot of these apps
come pre-installed on their
devices before they ever
install your app.
So they're learning
these patterns.
There's no need to really kind
of educate them further about
patterns they probably
already know.
ADAM KOCH: Mhm.
When it comes to help, you know,
the perfect place for
that is the overflow menu.
And I think earlier, Roman
had a link to the Design
Guidelines, which sort of goes
into a bit more detail on how
help should be structured
within your application.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, it's
basically like the difference
between unsolicited help
and solicited help.
ADAM KOCH: Mhm.
Users crying out for help.
ROMAN NURIK: Right.
ADAM KOCH: They're going to go
to the overflow and find what
they need there.
There are some times where
it's appropriate to have
onscreen overlays though.
So custom gestures like sort of
very specific gestures to
your application that are just
very custom an interesting and
different to other applications,
it can be
appropriate.
And a really good example of
that here that we have in the
screenshot is the YouTube
application.
And so in one of the more recent
updates, that YouTube
application actually allows you
to basically continue to
browse YouTube while minimizing
the current video
that's playing.
And so in the bottom right
there, that video would be
playing right now.
And the first time that you see
this in the new YouTube
application, it gives you this
little overlay so that you can
sort of understand the gestures
that you can apply to
that particular video.
So swiping there to the left
dismisses the video, and
swiping up actually maximizes
the video back into sort of
the fullscreen view.
ROMAN NURIK: Mhm, yep.
ADAM KOCH: So I think
this is a really
good use of an overlay.
ROMAN NURIK: Yep.
NICK BUTCHER: OK, so I think
that's all we have this week
on the onboarding experience.
So thanks very much
for joining us.
And as always, I'm your
host, Nick Butcher.
ROMAN NURIK: Roman Nurik.
ADAM KOCH: Adam Koch.
See you, guys.